is Amberly
here
Amberly she passed
away what a now convicted murderer
confesses to the crime on body camera
video when police knock on his door
looking for his girlfriend this after he
took out an insurance policy in her name
and lived with her dead body for
days you did
what I can't hear you I shot just last
month Tommy Powell was sentenced for the
crime he'd committed back in December of
2022 for the first time we're seeing
body camera recordings from First
Responders on the scene wait a minute is
Amberly
here
Amberly she passed
away what you did
what I can't I sh okay come here where
is she it happened in independ
attendance Kentucky just 20 minutes
south of Cincinnati on December 15th
2022 officers there responded to a
wellness call for Amberly Harris the
call came in from Harris's employer who
reported she hadn't been seen in
days 31 out of service I don't like
these
windows
video shows Powell answered the door for
officers and almost immediately admit
he' murdered Harris is Amberly
here
Amberly she passed
away what you did what
what where is
she
put watch she's in back what First
Responders act quickly rushing inside
the home to search for Harris no you're
going to put where is she watch in the
back
what Polie make yourself
known Independence Polie make yourself
known
Independence Police J make yourself no
go watch your footing watch your
footing in here huh
clear Independence Police here make S
known make SN
go oh she's down what she's down inside
First Responders find Harris's body
lying on the floor of a bedroom as
backup is called they work to secure the
rest of the apartment where they
eventually find a gun make sure you're
watching where you're standing and don't
touch anything yes
sir oh my
gosh when when did you do
this no one else is in here no keep them
coming
body camera video from multiple officers
shows the same moments from another
angle fire the ground yeah just stay
here you guys good yeah we're
good hold on hold onit
yes at the same time as officers
discover Harris's body others take
Powell into custody okay hold on come
here where is
she put put your hand my back watch
inside
what 26 hold Channel s sport units
Polie
okay you're good do you have any weapons
on you we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan the largest injury law firm in
America for sponsoring this video now
before you say oh great another Law Firm
ad first of all how dare you don't speak
that way of Morgan and Morgan and second
you don't know what makes them special
Morgan and Morgan has completely
modernized the personal injury claim
process they make it super easy for you
how you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents and you
talk to your whole legal Team all on
your phone now if you're injured at work
this isn't about suing your employer
it's about suing your employer's
insurance company which I got to tell
you is a huge relief because I love my
boss and you know what my boss loves me
honestly it's sad not everyone has our
kind of relationship it's no longer the
days of back-to-back meetings and
consultations an attorney is going to
review your case with eight clicks on
your phone that's it now you might be
saying sounds pretty expensive right
well here's the kicker there's no
upfront fee no you only pay them if you
win so it's no wonder over 3 million
people call them every year so if you're
injured you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com law and crime or by
dialing pound law that's pound 529 on
your phone subject door just admitted to
shooting our victim here so we're trying
to figure out
further the victim okay sit in your car
yeah we'll work that out in a second but
I got to make sure my gu's inside are
okay
just play pH all right RI you guys good
yeah we're good all right hold on hold
on I'm
sorry okay Tommy Powell doesn't seem
surprised when he's taken into custody
on December 15th
2022 in fact he anticipates the reading
of his Miranda rights Tommy I'm going to
read you something real quick okay R
right
yeah you're the right to main sign
anything you say can will be you get
used against you in court you have the
right to an attorney for make any
statement have your attorney with you
during question canot afford an attorney
desire one the court appoint one for you
may St question any Tom refus answer
further we're requesting assault with
your turn do you understand these rights
Tommy all right is there anyone else
inside is it just her oh my okay is it
just amly all right is it contained in
there when when did you do when did all
this just happen suay Monday morning
Sunday Monday morning Powell tells First
Responders where they will find the
murder weapon stashed under the bed
there a gun play view there's a gun in
one of the rooms down now the guns are
the
clear two and
three
possible fire him on the ground yeah
just s here back outside an officer puts
Powell into the back seat of a squad car
that's where he doubles down on his
confession we're going to go in to back
other side other side my
man a little too tight little too tight
hold on a
second just take a seat I'm going to
leave this door
cracked you
good do you need a squad or anything to
check you
out all right do you want to tell me
what happened
here fighting just trash my
again
do you want to tell me what happened
here when were you guys fighting Sunday
morning Sunday morning what started the
fight Flash my what was it I'm what
was it she was still on my TV and stuff
okay and then what happened I lost
control
you what now I lost control lost control
what made you lose control I don't
know are you
okay so when you say you lost control
what do you
mean what'd you shoot
with 20 gauge go ahead all right so was
a shotgun you shot her with hey I got to
get my body camera do you guys need
anything from the just at this
point I don't believe so all right Tommy
you okay right now
73 I'm going to keep my eyes on you but
I'm going to roll down this window a
little bit all right Powell admits he's
been in the home for days with Harris's
dead body do you know what today is
right
now how long you been inside the house
for 3 or 4 days have you left the house
or now 3 to seven there's no one else at
the office
You' been in shock
since
yeah
okay you don't know what today is
though
133 do you know what month it
is who's the
president officers then asked for
consent to search Powell's home
mirandize him he's been Miranda
mirandize him see if he'll give you sent
a search on the body Cam and if he gives
you consent we can Pro you can
process um and
then I don't know I mean by that whoever
I don't know if they're want to have
shine or whoever to come take him back
you they want well they'll probably want
to take him back and interviewing him
Tommy do we have consent to search your
whole
house yeah we do as the search continues
at the crime scene Powell is taken to
the Independence Police Station we're
going to walk into the office and we're
going to get in a room real quick all
right
good about pass out once inside an
interview room Powell gives police the
right to search his home once again I'm
detective sh with the offense police
this is detective young with okay I
don't know anything man I was at home
just kind of hanging out um apparently
we got a call to your home dud what the
what's going on
shot my girlfriend you shot your
girlfriend okay so real quick who who
lives
there who whose name's on the lease mine
your names on the lease okay so real
quick man
um do you mind if we search your
residence amidst the interview Powell
becomes sick and vomits into a trash can
is it like a stomach bug Tommy or do you
uh got the flu what's going going on
buddy talk to
me Co
okay oh so you haven't been to the
doctor even so the interview continues
and Powell signs off on the search of
his home kind of walk me through the
process of how this kind of went through
um and before we kind of begin with that
um we have officers that are at your
house right now okay uh obviously we
need to be able to kind of process that
scene effectively and what'll make that
scene processing a little bit easier is
if you take one his consent to search
form and allows access to search is that
okay okay so I'm going to walk this
through with you real quick okay so how
it works is that you're going to sign
your name right here but paramedics are
later called to the scene to check out
Powell's health status do you know where
you are right
now independence
what
okay do you want to go to the hospital
so I can see what's going on with you
please
I before he's taken to the hospital
police continue to ask Powell about the
murder and take photos of him have you
tried to communicate with anybody since
Sunday by a chance
no not like like family members any
other friends her friends perhaps you
haven't tried to talk to them at
all okay everybody stand up I'm going
take some pictures of you real quick
against this wall real quick with try to
be as quick as we can okay me a favor
stand up stand straight up this way kind
look at me please don't kick that over
goodness have a mess and these ladies
would kill me stand up against that wall
for
me see what happens
here after that Powell is taken to the
hospital and checked
out
look get inside here Tommy check your
temperature cheap out hey buddy I'm Dr
Patel can you tell me a little bit about
what happened to bring you
here or do you want some to step out a
little
bit we can't leave him he's in
our okay
he's been pretty for he's told us
everything that we need to know and
everything's going on with him he's been
a good man yeah and so what brings you
here
though meanwhile other officers process
the crime scene at Powell's apartment
they begin by confirming Harris is dead
said he shot her Monday uh her face is
covered she's down in between the bed
and the wall okay just give us if it's
obvious right now and there's no we
don't need any further care and so until
so we can uh yeah I just got to put it
on the monitor first before I say
yes all right so we got rer well Beck we
got rigger but we're not moving anything
until we get more people as more
officials arrive those first on the
scene explain what
happened I'm not
one we're going wait on we're going to
wait on that until more people hear
that's yeah okay I got his first I'm
going to put I got to put on for Le to
verify completely I want a time frame
between the bed and that's what we heard
he shot her Monday so well I I didn't
see what this initial call was a
wellbeing check somebody else called
about it yes okay and
yeah there's blood splatter on the wall
and she's covered up her face is covered
up yeah he covered her her do the wellbe
chck that dude he was here at the house
like we opened the he opened the door
and said I sh the initial search then
[Music]
continues Chief are you in here I'm
coming through with the camera on to do
a walk through there's a TV on the floor
in the bedroom where this occurred
that's just it looks like it may have
been on a like a a shelf or whatever may
have been knocked
off but other than that know it doesn't
look like it's destroyed looks like it's
been off the door does look like it's
been kicked off the hinges yeah make
sure you move this around right here get
whatever these are cuz it looks like
these pills might be
everywhere you want to call list just to
help out
we investigators later determined a
$20,000 insurance policy was taken out
in Harris's name the month before her
murder Powell was listed as the
beneficiary Powell pleaded guilty to a
murder charge and was sentenced to life
in prison just last month reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie